fresh milk from local farms kept at 30
degrees Celsius rennet is added until
current forms then the milk is drained
salted and matured for up to 12 weeks to
make this French breed here at one of
the last two companies to make the
cheese the traditional way nearly every
part of the process is done by hand only
thing we could mechanize the process but
that would change our recipe we would
end up with a different kind of cheese
the cheese we sent to the US is made
with the same process except the milk is
pasteurized but the quality is the same
so City of Omaha de la brie employs 65
people it's resisted the threat of
industrialized rivals but now there's a
new problem russia's embargo on some
European foods laughs back to the impact
of the Russian embargo could be much
more violent and quicker than expected
we have prices of milk have collapsed
and unfortunately we fear that this may
last until the end of the year or even
later nearly 40% of the production here
is exported Russia may be a small market
but it was one of the fastest growing
with French exports tripling over the
past four years always face is worse for
Russia about 100,000 pcs language it's a
small cheese in the tin box and it was
very easy to say for Russia in total
this exporter could lose more than 1
million euros of 4% of his annual
revenue unless he can find a new guy
he'll be left with a salt taste and
smell